let's bring in our military analyst
retired Air Vice Marshall Sean Bell
hello Sean
um big meetings going on today uh let's
talk about president zielinski first in
Poland it's his first official visit as
we've said before he's traveled through
the country since the War Began but
what's he hoping to achieve from today
yes there's a series of big visits going
on and the dangers they just look like
routine these are nothing like routine
they've got real strategic importance as
you say President zelensky visiting
um DOTA the leader of Poland they've got
a range of issues to discuss they've got
some literally some of the more routine
issues like grain Ukrainian grayness is
the market it's duty-free at the moment
and as a result the drain grain prices
plummeted in Poland that's angered the
farmers and therefore they're a bit
upset about all that but the main issue
they're going to be discussing this
visit is the war in Ukraine uh Poland
for all sorts of geographic and
historical reasons is very concerned
about what Putin's wider Ambitions are
Beyond Ukraine and over 80 percent of
the Polish population want to back fully
the support for Ukraine and therefore
doda's been providing political and
Military Support and has actually lent
into providing things like MiG-29 Jets
as well and has been the first nation to
do that so it's also worth noting though
that on a slightly more Grand strategic
scale with the U.S presidential
elections not close but the attention
start to be drawn by that and also U.S
made very clear that China is its number
one priority whilst America will remain
the number one donor of both money and a
military machinery for Ukraine there is
a gap for some European leadership in
the support of Ukraine and that seems to
be an area that Poland's stepping up to
and president Pete in busy today lots of
meetings we saw him addressing his um
Security Council a little early has also
been welcoming new ambassadors including
the new U.S ambassador
um but the president of Belarus has been
to Moscow Alexander lukashenko what's
that visit all about another one this is
this latest in a whole series of visits
now President Putin's made no secret of
his desires to sort of Reform the so
Soviet Union the trouble is the Baltic
states are now part of NATO so you can't
restore those he invaded Ukraine to stop
that falling into NATO's hands and
Belarus he's installed a puppet regime
and that's what lukashenko is doing one
of the key things they're going to be
discussing is the union state treaty now
this has been on the table of some time
it's stalled for some time but it's
almost a borderless alliance between the
two countries and given the probably the
challenges that Putin's facing in
Ukraine he's trying to rush this through
and gain some traction now of course the
two are actually pretty close already
the Russians are doing military training
in Belarus they've conducted operations
against Ukraine from Belarus and soil
they're basing military jets there and
we've recently reported they're putting
tactical nuclear weapons in Belarus
trouble is for lukashenko he's survived
a few riots he's not the most popular
leader in in the country and he's going
to therefore take care but it's pretty
evident that Putin solved the Ukraine
problem using his military force he's
now trying to solve the Belarus Problem
by leveraging every tool at his disposal
is political Arsenal to tighten the grip
on that country and just while we have
you Sean a quick update on developments
on the ground in Ukraine quick cancer
through uh in back mooch we were
reporting how the vital group were
making progress they have taken the
center of the city the um the city um
Council headquarters it's a part of
rubble to be fair so it's symbolic
rather than actually uh meaty but it has
they are continuous slow grinding War of
Attrition up there I think from military
perspective what doesn't make sense at
the moment is that Russians know that
Ukraine's are going to be mounting some
sort of counter-attack so they really
should be preserving their combat power
for that in Crimea down to the South
they're built they're building up lots
of defenses
um but actually they're continuing full
bore in bakmud so you have to conclude
that Russia's special military operation
is all about preserving Crimea and
taking the whole of the donbass the
challenge is that that's likely to
Simply fuel Ukraine's Ambitions for the
forthcoming spring offensive